Yves, ein ernstes Thema:
Hast du Angst vor dem Tod?
Ich halte es
mit dem antiken Philosophen Epikur:
Vor dem Tod
müssen wir keine Angst haben.
Solange wir da sind,
ist der Tod nicht da.
Und wenn der Tod da ist,
sind wir nicht mehr da.
Ich habe keine Angst, tot zu sein.
Aber vor dem Sterben?
Vor dem Sterben ...
Angst ist es nicht.
Ich möchte nicht, dass ich
aus dem Leben gerissen werde,
bevor es an ein Ende gekommen ist.
Es ist eine Zumutung.
Es ist scheisse,
dass wir so früh sterben müssen.
Ich würde gerne länger leben
als die durchschnittlich 80 Jahre.
Ich glaube, Angst vor dem Sterben
haben viele Leute,
weil wir es gewöhnt sind,
alles kontrollieren zu können.
Das hat Blaise Pascal gesagt.
Er wisse nicht, was der Tod ist.
Er wisse nur ganz sicher,
dass wir sterben müssen.
Aber über den Tod und das Sterben
wissen wir nichts.
Es kam noch keiner zurück.
Wir wissen nicht, wie es ist,
tot zu sein oder zu sterben.
Nochmals zurück
zum Argument von Epikur.
Es überzeugt mich nicht.
Wenn wir nicht mehr da sind,
kann nichts für uns schlecht sein.
Darum sagt er,
der Tod gehe uns nichts an.
Wir erleben den Tod nicht.
Er kann nicht schmerzhaft sein
oder nicht.
- Wir sind dann weg.
- Ist es darum kein Problem? - Ja.
Das überzeugt mich nicht.
Die Endlichkeit ist ein Problem.
Aber der Tod als Zustand ...
Ist es ein Zustand?
Man ist ja nur Körper.
Was könnte dagegen sprechen?
Es gibt
ein grosses, wichtiges Argument:
das Deprivationsargument.
Thomas Nagel meint,
das eigentliche Problem am Tod sei,
dass dir etwas weggenommen wird -
nämlich deine weitere Existenz.
Dieses Wegnehmen ist
selbstverständlich schlecht für dich.
Und wenn die Menschen gemäss Epikur
sagen, es sei nicht schlecht,
weil man es nicht merkt, zeigt er
Beispiele auf, wieso es nicht stimmt.
Man muss das Argument so lesen ...
Man erlebt das Tot-Sein nicht.
Das wollte er damit sagen.
Aber ist das beruhigend?
Oder das Grundproblem?
Ist es nicht eher die Angst vor
dem Sterben oder der Endlichkeit?
Oder weil man nicht sterben will?
Man kann es als gültiges Argument
rekonstruieren.
Aber es trifft nicht unsere Sorge.
Es gibt noch
die Diskussion um Lukrez.
Der fragte sich,
wieso wir ein Problem mit dem Sterben
und dem Tod haben sollen.
Es gab ja auch eine Zeit,
in der wir noch nicht da waren.
Das ist ein total interessantes
Argument. Es ist faszinierend.
Es ärgert einen,
dass man dann nicht mehr da ist.
Die Vorstellung dieses Zustands
geht nicht.
Aber dieser Ärger, dass man weg ist,
hat man nur
in Bezug auf die Zukunft.
- Davor hatte man nichts
zu verlieren. - Ja. Deprivation.
Genau. Jetzt hat man gelebt,
hat Beziehungen, die wichtig sind.
- Die sind nachher ...
- Man hat etwas zu verlieren.
- Wie möchtest du mal sterben?
- Wie du es vorhin gesagt hast.
- Schön.
- Wir sind uns für einmal einig.
Mit dem Gefühl eines Abschlusses.
Wenn man sich
nochmals bedanken konnte.
Wenn man Abschied nehmen konnte.
Eigentlich ein bewusster Tod.
Wenn man Umfragen glaubt,
möchten viele Menschen
am liebsten einen Sekundentod -
von heute auf morgen ist es fertig.
Kein Sterbeprozess also,
sondern ein abruptes Ende.
Ein abruptes Ende
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Fürs Erleben
wäre das andere vielleicht besser.
Es geht schneller.
Man leidet nicht lange.
Genau. Die Angst vor dem Leiden
habe ich auch.
Wir können sowieso nicht wählen.
Es ist unverfügbar.
Doch. Heute kann man das teilweise.
Beispielsweise Bilanzsuizid.
Also dass man mit Suizidbeihilfe
aus dem Leben scheidet.
Vielleicht nicht mal,
weil man schwer krank ist
und Angst vor Schmerzen hat,
sondern weil man denkt, es sei genug,
das Leben sei gelebt.
Gerade Alt-68er, die älter werden,
haben ein starkes Bedürfnis,
einen selbstbestimmten Tod zu leben
und vielleicht
über den Zeitpunkt zu verfügen.
Das spricht doch
aus deiner Sicht dafür.
Dann kann man alle abschliessenden
Handlungen vornehmen,
Abschied nehmen, sich bedanken usw.
Und dann gehen.
Ich würde mir viele Gedanken darüber
machen, wie es für diejenigen ist,
die man zurücklässt.
Hätten die nicht immer das Gefühl,
mich davon abhalten zu müssen?
Darüber spricht man zu wenig.
Und es gibt noch andere Fragen.
Wie ist es, wenn man
den Todeszeitpunkt genau kennt?
Das möchte ich nicht.
Ein Zeitraum von einer Woche bis
drei Monate - wäre das dein Ideal?
Wenn man Abschied nimmt
und noch zehn Jahre lebt ...
Das wäre blöd, nicht?
Das ist eher blöd, stimmt.
Es wäre aber ein schöner Gedanke.
"Memento mori" -
das Leben im Angesicht des Todes.
Es gibt Philosophen, die sagen,
das mache den Wert des Lebens aus.
Es wertet das Leben
und die Ereignisse auf.
Dass wir wissen, es ist einzigartig
und nicht immer repetierbar.
Sondern es ist ein kostbares Gut.
Das Gut ist begrenzt.
Das zeigt z.B.
ein Roman von Simone de Beauvoir:
"Alle Menschen sind sterblich".
Die Hauptfigur Raymond Fosca
lebt unendlich lange.
Mit der Zeit hat er alles gemacht.
Er kennt das Schlechte
und das Scheitern des Menschen
von allen Seiten -
und irgendwann wird es absurd,
langweilig und sinnlos.
Das wäre ...
... eine Bestätigung dafür,
dass die Begrenztheit diesem
Abschnitt einen gewissen Wert gibt.
Es ist eine grosse Diskussion -
die Unsterblichkeitsdebatte.
Google gehört das Unternehmen Calico
im Silicon Valley,
das versucht, den Code
des ewigen Lebens zu knacken.
Es gibt unterschiedliche Strategien.
Einige sagen, irgendwann
könne man das menschliche Gehirn
auf einen Chip laden
und in einen anderen Körper pflanzen.
Dann könne man
in einer Maschine leben.
Andere sagen, der Alterungsprozess
müsste nicht sein.
Man könnte den biologischen Zelltod
irgendwann ausschalten.
Ich halte das alles für Spinnereien
und leere Versprechungen.
- Das wird wohl nie kommen.
- Das kannst du nicht beurteilen.
Aber die Frage ist ...
Die Frage ist,
ob es wünschenswert ist.
Ja. Simone de Beauvoir
hat versucht zu zeigen,
dass es nicht wünschenswert ist.
Man sollte wählen können,
wie lange man lebt.
Das finde ich ...
Es ist zwar fast eine Art
Gotteslästerung und undemütig.
Aber Selbstbestimmung über die
Lebensspanne ist erstrebenswert.
Das passt zur Generation Maybe.
Man kann alles verschieben.
Ich glaube, dass die Kürze
und Begrenzung des Lebens
wie eine Lupe, ein Brennglas wirkt.
Sie zeigt dir, dass du früh siehst,
was wirklich wichtig ist.
Viele Menschen stellen sich
in der Mitte des Lebens die Frage,
was zählt, was sie noch wollen.
Wenn das Durchschnittsalter
nur 40 Jahre wäre,
wären die einzelnen Momente
noch wertvoller.
Man könnte alles nur einmal haben.
Man möchte doch trotzdem
immer noch ein wenig mehr.
Auch das noch erleben.
Die Welt verändert sich.
Der schwedische Philosoph Nick
Bostrom und auch Julian Savulescu -
diese Transhumanisten ...
- Total durchgeknallt.
Aber vielleicht
ist das die Philosophie ...
Vielleicht
schaut man in 200 Jahren zurück
und findet deine Meinung
so was von konservativ.
Wir sind einfach noch verhaftet
an dem, was wir Mensch nennen.
Es wird etwas Neues,
Besseres, Freieres entstehen können.
Darauf sage ich dann immer:
Das sind die Transhumanisten.
Diese Wesen, die es dann geben wird,
sind keine Menschen
im engeren Sinn mehr.
Was für die gut ist, weiss ich nicht.
Ich bin ein Mensch.
Und Giraffen sind Giraffen.
Ich habe meine Grenzen.
Es wird auch dort noch
unverfügbare Sachen geben.
Nur schon,
dass man eine Lungenentzündung
mit Penicillin heilen kann ...
Das ist ein Eingriff ins Natürliche.
Das gehört doch dazu.
Ich bin keine Anhängerin
des bloss Natürlichen.
Der Mensch ist ein Kulturwesen.
Den Alterungsprozess
kann man genauso definieren.
"Krankheit zum Tode". Jetzt kann man
es heilen und das Leben verlängern.
So sehen es die Transhumanisten.
Stimmt.
Was spricht denn rational dagegen?
Vielleicht aus Nostalgie,
als romantisches Argument
eines Menschen,
der jetzt zufälligerweise ist,
wie er ist.
Unser Leben hat sich in den letzten
200 Jahren recht verändert.
-Die Bedingungen
und die Lebensgestaltung. - Stimmt.
Habt ihr Angst vor dem Tod?
Eure Meinung interessiert uns.
Schreibt sie uns doch.
Wie eine Bestatterin
über den Tod und das Sterben denkt,
haben wir in diesem Gespräch
da drüben diskutiert.
Wenn ihr nichts mehr verpassen wollt,
aktiviert die Glocke.